[Music]
man oh man I know everyone's been
looking forward to this
not supposedly seeing me but it's the
end so I'm gonna try to make this as
quick as possible and I don't know I
guess or my slides gonna show eventually
I sure hope so
shout out to the AV people because
they're the best
alright the slides supposed to show I
don't know
I hope so cuz I'm not gonna be able to
act this out the whole time
oh there we go so quickly I mean I
realized that I saw a speaker yesterday
and she kind of like matched her slides
with her outfit so I thought I might do
the same and so if everything goes right
I'm gonna disappear and I'm gonna
reappear again it's like camouflage okay
it worked
Eddie how I thought that was kind of
funny and you're gonna find out I'm a
bit of a comedian so we're gonna start
this with with a joke is that cool can
we have a joke alright how many
JavaScript is here I mean it's kind of
funny that I don't see all the hands up
but that's cool so imagine if Naughty by
Nature
went to the tc39 meeting hip hop array
oh hey oh oh you didn't like that it's
all good
anyhow we're gonna get things cracking
yes my name is Augie my real last name
is not Helvetica I just thought it
sounded kind of cool so I did it anyways
a lot of people might recognize me from
my face which is the avatar that I kind
of like - I'm from the greatest city on
the planet called Toronto it's super
multicultural and I didn't realize it
till I left and I was like man Toronto
is actually amazing so if you
in the area come by and check us out we
we like to have some good times and
here's a little something you may not
have known about Toronto how many old
schoolers here anyone own a Commodore 64
back in the day yeah well Commodores
found it in Toronto yeah no doubt
anyhow so we're gonna get things going
welcome to the shape of the web it's a
talk that I thought about a while back
and and sort of just to talk about like
where the web was gone a lot of good
things have happened a lot of technology
was used to make things really sort of
like friendly and user like the great
user experiences that we try to create
but also felt that you know the
technologists that are involved were
amazing but also there are some
technologists who may have been left
behind so we're gonna kind of
conversation about that and it's really
just a conversation so let's get
cracking now first off I want to thank
Jes coffee you for having me I've been
watching this conference from a distance
like on Twitter and I would look at the
photos like wow this is amazing look at
the screen no seriously look at the
screen I mean I own an ultra-wide at
home and I think that this ratio is like
15 to 2 which is bananas like talk about
neck pains but dev tools would be
amazing on the screen by the way
festival X 10 years and I come from
music so I could appreciate what they've
done here the set up I mean it's
absolutely laborat but I love that
they've done this for a TED conference
so can we please give Jay's Khan for
round of applause as well all right
that's enough I'm gonna get jealous so
they've been around 10 years and I was
thinking to myself like you know I was
kind of you know brightness talk up
adding some notes 10 years where was I
10 years ago well like I said I came
from music and I was able to pull this
this photo out I used to do lectures
with the Red Bull Music Academy which is
actually based out of Germany and I was
doing a lecture here with Flying Lotus
and that's that was like a big deal for
me at the time but that's actually 10
years from about like a week
from today so it's pretty on point and
on brand but the web the web is actually
30 years 30 years old and I was thinking
to myself like man 3 years old that's
all that's that's kind of like a long
time and I don't know where you were 30
years ago but I remember when I first
access the web the first thing I thought
of was was this and I don't know how
many of you were able to sort of like be
around this time where you had to get it
a modem and you made all that telephone
sounds and all that stuff just to get on
the internet but it was great because I
discovered a lot of things and there's
one place I used to hang out which was
uh who remembers like news groups here
go okay there we go
this where hung out a lot Rek thought
music not hip-hop and I was like yeah
man I'm gonna talk about hip hop with
all these people I don't know but this
was actually the first time you started
to connect with people from all parts of
the world who had access to the net and
another thing that I did as I had more
and more access
I used to use search engines like
everyone else and who remembers
AltaVista okay there we go I was a big
fan of AltaVista man when that will not
vanish I was so sad but what I also did
was I start to surf the web and I was a
big Netscape Navigator and communicator
fan and actually being I mean there was
a few browsers around there after but
this the one that I was using and the
big part about this one is when it was
released this is what there's one of the
early quotes from Andreessen himself
this software is going to change
everything and it kind of did and why
was it so popular well well let me get
into another court actually before that
he's another fantastic quote that came
out from another influential person in
tech at the time things start exploding
with the invention of the browser
because suddenly the internet was
accessible to the average person and I
mean average will say sort of like
middle class person who had a computer
who had a modem but it definitely opened
things up and you start to sort of like
have that delight and discovery that I
like to talk about now
when Netscape came out it was extremely
popular 65 million users in 18 months
and part of the reason was the fact that
as much as the early web was like text
it was very academic but they were
actually able to bring images into the
fold here and what then happened is that
when we were surfing the net
we were very accustomed to the layout
text images it was like reading the
paper and believe it or not there was
debate as to whether or not they were
gonna bring images onto the web you know
some mild arguments and the belief was
that if they brought images on it would
be like this onslaught of pornography
and I'm here to say that they were
absolutely wrong right
but the fact is for real though they
believe that by opening it up adding
some images and letting people sort of
experiment it was going to drive the web
forward and it actually did now today we
have 4.3 billion users online and I
think that's phenomenal but believe it
or not there's still room to grow and
you know you might wonder like okay
that's an explosive growth what sort of
drove that well this is kind of it right
here this young lady is on a mobile
phone I believe this is nothing that
they expected to see at the time this is
like mid 90s who thought that you are
gonna have a mobile device and be able
to surf the web just as powerfully as
they did back then so this has allowed
us to do a lot of different things we've
been able to be very productive in life
so what have we been able to do with
sort of like little friction pretty much
everything I mean we can make money we
manage money online we can go on a date
we can go buy clothes for the we can
actually go rent the car to take your
date out we can order fish we can listen
to one of my favorite songs called fish
and we could actually get phishing
emails from African Prince's right but
all jokes aside man we can actually read
comics and make them accessible comic
books shout outs to Jessica no doubt for
all the people that were trying to bring
online we could actually go offline this
is what technologies it allowed us to do
which is absolutely needed by the way I
downloaded the offline map for Berlin
because I was not going to pay those
fees but we could actually create music
in the browser as well sat outs live Jas
alright in the building this is the kind
of technology this is what the
technology has allowed us to do very
important now and this is the shape of
the web as we see it growing growing
right before our eyes so the technology
has been extremely important in getting
these sort of these things done and this
is where we are going to sort of like
see even more technology allow us to do
greater things thereafter now what about
the technologists we may have been
playing some amazing chords on some of
the devices that we've seen out there
you know from keyboard select immediate
controllers but unfortunately there's
been a little bit of discord as well and
we're gonna get into a few sort of like
items that I've sort of been bothering
me a little so let's talk about women
technology I mean there's an ongoing
refrain we know exactly what's going on
and he actually kind of saddens me I
mean you just need to open up Twitter
and wait about like five seconds before
he hits you and I think that's sad it's
been long discussed you know what needs
to be done to retain talent to to
attract talent and we still go out and
sort of like trip over some of the main
issues I mean what do they talk about
what do women talk about when they sort
of leave the industry you know the lack
of
growth salary poor management and you
know when I read poor management I know
exactly what they mean that's just being
polite
whoops and the other part is actually
what scares me because the other I feel
I know exactly what's going on but again
it's being polite and not really calling
people up because other to me means
exactly this you know it's not fit for
print but we know exactly what's
happening and to me that's absolutely
not the way or the shape of the web
needs to take further on so I'm gonna
share a little story something that I
sort of like did a few years ago now
International Women's Day happens once
here March 8th and I got together with
some buddies I'm like man let's let's
rap about this and I want to put an
event together for women to come out and
enjoy themselves and speak to other
women and listen to other women in the
industry and this goes back to something
I tried about 10 years ago in music I
really wanted to do a show with female
producers I work in a certain type of
sounds and you know I knew there were
producers out there but when I went
knocking on some doors I couldn't find
any sponsors X Y & Z so it got a little
tough but I never forgot that so when I
had an opportunity to do something again
I did so every year some buddies of mine
put together this event called iw DTO
International Wednesday and this is a
picture of 2017 because we've been doing
it for five years now and on from the
right to left we have Lisa Eagle after
she actually worked at the White House
she was an Obama hire by the way the
lady in the middle someone who I look up
to very much she works in performance
she goes by the name of Tammy Everts
she works at a speed curve an amazing
person you need to follow her if you can
and of course on the left I'm not sure
if she's here but Mina Markham I was
super happy to have her come down no
doubt and have her share her story
because I thought that was important but
the most important part is the fact that
like I said we do this every year and it
warms my heart to be able to sort of
help
in a way I might not be the best ally
but I feel like I'm doing a little
something to make things work why do I
want to do this well I want to make sure
that we have moments like these you know
we know Kitty boo thank you thank you
thick katie booming we know exactly what
happened there a great moment even
though shortly after we saw the trolls
come out and sort of questioner Margaret
Hamilton as we know coin the term
software engineering but right there
she's sitting next to the stack of paper
that was essentially her sort of like
tracing or helping get the the Rockets
out to the moon but one of my favorite
photos is this one right here this is
the Indian Space Research Organization
and they're having a ball right there
why well they were the fourth team to
ever get a satellite around Mars but
they were the first to do it on the
first try not NASA not the European
Space Agency and not the Russians
patients you see but the agency out of
India and as you can tell the team is
made up of several women this is
actually a short documentary on that
documentary on that I'll be more than
happy to put the link out so I want to
see more of these happening these
moments taking place and the big thing
is that the common thread between the
three photos that I showed I mean they
all had CS backgrounds degrees and
whatnot which brings me to my my next
malaise the CS versus non CS beef any CS
people in the building I mean raise your
hand I got love for you you know I mean
how did this happen I really don't know
but I kind of got triggered by this one
tweet and this person's gonna go
unidentified reasons why computer
science degree is a bad idea
what money times yes can be so boring
etc etc and
to myself that was actually kind of
irresponsible because it came from
someone who has a large platform and I
actually questioned him on it but I'm
not going to get into that but I will
get into this and make some noise when
you see a photo that sort of like you
recognize the image okay all right
does anyone know what this is okay I'm
gonna get into that but does anyone know
what this is okay so let me go back dope
stands for Dartmouth oversimplified
programming experiment it was the
language that preceded basic and we know
that basic is beginners all-purpose
symbolic instruction code why is this
important
the the the author of basic John Kennedy
a math wizard worked at Dartmouth
believed that he can get non-stem
students at the university to get into
programming and he basically soldiered
on trying to make things work and
eventually basic did become a language
and how did it happen because he got a
lot of non stem students to work along
and contribute to the to the venture and
basic was born and that's very important
because even as a non stem student
you're in basic this is a tweet from
Brian loves words where is he Brian you
in the building I boom I thought this
was so true you needed to sort of like
see this because you don't need a CS
degree to be successful but it doesn't
mean by having a CX degree you're not
going to be and in fact John Kennedy's
daughter mentioned this basic was
basically an incredible project of Anna
and what is now called an inline team so
I thought that was wild
but speaking of CS I want to talk about
something else real quick does anyone
who know where this is probably not
her name's Lena so Soderbergh but most
of the CS people and
anyone's in performance they might know
this name Lenna or Linna okay we know
someone here knows but you might
recognize it when I do this now this is
the photo that's been internationally
accepted as the test image when you do
any kind of image processing compressing
Excel etc which is totally cool but
here's what's not so cool this is where
it came from I remember doing some
research one day and I could not believe
it we have been using an image from
Playboy for forty some years do you know
that two million images are uploaded to
the web daily oh never say two million
I'm at 2 billion images are uploaded to
the web daily but somehow we have the
photo centerfold as the test pattern I
mean the test image for image
compression you know and for a second I
was thinking ah you know it's the 40s
you know we're gonna get over it
whatever it's it's gonna sort of fade
this happened in 2018 someone presented
a talk and just like talked about
centerfolds 2018 how are you supposed to
retain talent how are you supposed to
attract talent when you have this kind
of comportment out in the wild this is
not the shape of the web to come and
with that being said I mean I tweeted
this out just moments before I got on
stage
I'll ask anyone who wishes to do so to
vote whether or not the Lenna image
should remain the standard in image
processing now we kind of know what this
means the world wide web developer I
know Alexis I call it the wealthy
Western web ok I'm good because I think
this started early sorry I'm watching
the clock and this flashing anyhow the
wealthy Western web because we know that
you know we like to design and create
apps for like you know the West but what
if I told you this is the list of the
topped em Internet users by country okay
what if I told you the greatest growth
by country looks like this now these two
lists are the reason why documentation
is important and is important to
translate think about this remember that
the gentleman spoke yesterday who said
you know he has spoken a few times on
stage but it was his first time speaking
in English first time and you have
developers out there that are trying to
you know get in the fold but
documentation is not in their native
language that's something we definitely
have to look into why because you have
situations like this and this sort of
caused a little bit of kerfuffle once on
Twitter and I was watching it and this
tweet came out I'm not going to name the
person because I didn't ask whether or
not you know I could use it but and this
happened thereafter same tweet now we
are talking about you know creating an
inclusive community an inclusive web I
mean I don't know how you're going to
get more inclusive than having
documentation translated properly so
that other developers can have some
input think about your framework that
may sort of like mature so much faster
because you have contributions from all
over the globe because they have
documentation in their native tongue I
think it's very important to remember
that being said I mean what's next in
2020 I don't know I think we're also
gonna be developers we're all still
gonna love the web we're all still gonna
go to conferences we're all still gonna
network kick it with folks we're all
still gonna have great discoveries I
mean there's so much web we have
yet to discover there's so many more
people that we can help the light in
discovery I mean there's so many more
applications we have yet to sort of
engineer people neighbors so many people
we can learn from experiences you know
just so that we can make tweaks to our
applications but at the end of the day I
know we're good people by default I mean
I I truly believe that I don't think
that we're born with like sort of like
evil within us at least I sure hope not
my hope is that we keep it as such I
mean we get to maybe one day enjoy
another coffee UJS Khan for you because
I'd love to come back and with that
being said thank you very much for your
time come visit me in Toronto and let's
party tonight
[Applause]
[Music]